my mom was all about you know always
give it your 120
there's always this concept of
that extra 20 that's the difference
between a good result and an exceptional
result that was really instilled in me
very early on and it tends to be true
with everything i've done so far
i'm tarek i'm co-founder and ceo at
kalshi and i'm 25.
calcium is a financial exchange that
allows people to trade on the outcome of
events so the way i always like to
describe it is that we're developing a
new asset class so the same way that you
can trade equities and commodities and
rates you can now trade on this thing
called event contracts
where you can essentially simply buy yes
and no shares and whether
brexit is going to happen whether
kovalev is going to get worse this fall
or whether it's going to rain tomorrow
i think the novelty with kelsey is that
we're the first federally regulated
exchange that is allowed to do this my
co-founder luan and i took 2.5 years to
get it regulated and we finally got to
launch this year
i was always
really into math i was the math nerd in
class and so that sort of you know led
me to get into mit it was a big dream of
mine when i was growing up you know math
nerd and mit made sense and nmit got
exposed to finance which felt like this
was
something that was really appealing to
me then i realized in finance i i i was
something about it i liked being a
trader but that wasn't what i wanted to
do
i was more interested in
the structure of the whole system
i got said about financial history and
then this is when one was telling me
about the idea and
it all fit together it was like i love
finance
it's going to be hard which i think felt
really exciting there's one day where i
want to convince me to call both of us
called 65 lawyers in one day all of
which said absolutely not we're not
we're not touching this it's not going
to happen you know people have been
trying since the 80s and 90s and it's
not happening and we kept on pushing
until we finally got regulated on
november 3rd 2020 actually the day of
the elections we basically unlocked a
whole new asset class for the us
i think the 10-year vision is we want to
live in a world where event contracts
are something that's commonplace
there's really a big market that
hopefully you know would leave us with
some amount of legacy
[Music]
you